il commençait india ta culotte me gêne
d'accord une petite je te passe une
serviette tu l'enlèves est comme ça tu
la mets sur toi et ça ne me gênera pas
donc moi pas j'ai été bouffés par la
peur à ce moment-là je me dis mais si tu
le fait pas qu'est ce qu'il va faire moi
je me souviens juste de ce moment là du
début à la fin je voulais que tu n'as
qu'une envie c'était de sortir de sortir
de la pièce quoi et du coup il masse
après les les jambes et puis vient aux
adducteurs et c'est là pour mandat main
est parti trop en quoi ça a duré une
fraction de seconde mais cette façon ce
monde qu'ils ont est pas dieu
déjà dès le début ça aurait pas dû
commencer l'aurait jamais tu me
demandait d'enlever le rein pont sous
vêtements enfin c est la première fois
qu il m'a demandé d'enlever d'enlever ma
culotte pour mettre une serviette la
toute première fois hervé pas eu de
débordement je me souviens être sorti de
la chambre et la garantie est une fille
qui nagent avec moi et m'a ri au nez
du coup tout de suite ça m'a on s'est
intéressé aux violences sexuelles en
milieu sportif
on a trouvé 70 cette affaire avec des
dysfonctionnements graves qui ont
provoqué 276 victimes en milieu sportif
en grande majorité des mineurs de moins
de 15 ans et dans 28 disciplines
sportives ça va du football vous échec à
l'équitation à l'athlétisme c'est tous
les sports qui sont concernés
[Musique]
un cas sur deux dans nous à faire dans
nos 77 à faire c'était des personnes qui
avaient déjà condamné par le passé pour
des infractions sexuelles souvent ces
personnes se font oublier parfois le
change de région aujourd'hui à plus de 3
millions de bénévoles lancé par français
donc c'est énorme les bénévoles ne sont
pas contrôlés au niveau du casier
judiciaire est dû ce qu'on appelle le
pij et à c'est à dire le fichier des
infractions sexuelles leurs antécédents
judiciaires ne sont pas contrôlés donc
si je résume quelqu'un qui aurait été
condamné pour viol sur mineure on a des
cas peut se retrouver
entraîneur auprès de mineurs quelques
années quelques années après sa
condamnation
les clubs sont parfois de mauvaise
volonté dans le sens où ils veulent
protéger leurs institutions
mais on a aussi pas mal de cas où les
clubs les instances sportives les
fédérations les ligues sont dans une
méconnaissance totale par rapport à
cette affaire l'a souvent un niveau
amateur ce qu'on a une majorité de
petits amateurs dans les petits villages
dans les clubs de quartiers on a un peu
démuni quand surgissent au genre
d'affaires qu'est ce qu'on doit faire et
ce qu'on doit dénoncer est ce qu'on doit
suspendre est-ce qu'on doit interdire
est ce qu'on doit prévenir les parents
et là dessus c'est l'énorme boulot que
devrait faire davantage
le ministère des sports la ministre des
sports oksana maracineanu qui est
l'ancien champion du monde
de natation se mobilisent sur ce sujet
là depuis qu'elle arrive depuis un peu
plus d'un an ministère des sports mais
il est clair que j'étais la première à
prendre officiellement la parole dessus
parce que jusqu'à maintenant il y avait
une omerta s'est quand même passé la
saison et c'est toujours dur de faim
voilà on m'a dit c'est les dernières
étapes c'est bientôt fini
mais c'est toujours dur de se replonger
dedans de repenser à tout ça
on voulait vous parlez du csm clamart
qui est un club que vous connaissez bien
votre fille s'entraîne et où vous êtes
maintenant même licencié un entraîneur a
été écarté du club parce que il est
accusé aujourd'hui avoir commis des
attouchements sur une jeune femme une
athlète du club
est ce que vous étiez au courant est ce
que vous êtes au courant de cette
histoire j'étais au courant de cette
histoire puisque dans ma vie associative
j'intervenais aux côtés du club dans une
autre association donc je connaissais
cette personne qui est aujourd'hui mise
en examen voilà je le connais vous
pourra pour avoir travaillé à ses côtés
dans la même veine dans le même
établissement
le 26 septembre 2018 il ya un an vous
avez reçu ce courrier que vous
connaissez de la part d'un avocat qui
vous a demandé de diligenter une enquête
administrative sur le fonctionnement du
club
on en est où par rapport à ça est ce que
vous avez dirigeante et une enquête
administrative sur le csm clamart
mais écoutez cette affaire s'est passé
en 2000
15 de mémoire 2016 elle a démarré par
une dépôt de plainte pour du harcèlement
moral donc sur le fils de la famille
dont l'avocat ici m'a effectivement
adressé ce courrier dès mon arrivée au
ministère pour me réinformer de de ce
cas que je connaissais déjà il ne
s'agissait pas d'un dépôt de plainte
pour agression sexuelle mais du
harcèlement moral et le courrier mais
arrivés par voie personnelle j'allais
dire plus pour information que pour une
intervention ministérielle les éléments
qu'on a eu c'est qu'il ya eu en 2012 et
en 2014 des alertes qui prévenait déjà
d'une relation particulière entre
l'entraîneur et cette jeune athlète qui
dit aujourd'hui avoir subi des
attouchements et donc une agression
sexuelle et ces alertes elles ont été
remontés devant le bureau du club de
l'époque et pour autant on sait que le
bureau n'a pas agi de 2012 à 2016 2017
c'est pour ça qu'on revient aujourd'hui
avec cette question en se demandant si
on peut imaginer qu'il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements au sein du bureau du
club
pourquoi ne pas délirante et une enquête
administrative pour des certaine manière
faire la lumière sur ce qui s'est passé
au sein de ce club pendant cinq ans
écoutez moi je n'ai pas connaissance de
ces
alerte qui ont été lancés depuis 2012 je
pense qu'elles ont été versées au
dossier sans doute de cette enquête et
l' enquête qui est en cours pourra aussi
déterminer s'il faut remettre en
question en cause les personnes qui
auraient été au courant et qu'ils
n'auraient pas réagi à l'époque je suis
pas dans le concret de l'enquète je suis
pas dans le quotidien donc je peux pas
vous dire et d'ailleurs maintenant en
tant que ministre je peux pas intervenir
sur une enquête en cours sur laquelle
judy ci a bien sûr mais c'est pour ça
que j'insiste là dessus c'est que dans
ce courrier il vous parle précisément
d'une enquête administrative
[Musique]
m
je juge personnellement que le l'organe
dirigeant du club et les personnes en
place n'ont pas du tout l'intention ne
sont pas là pour couvrir des faits de ce
type là au contraire ils sont plutôt là
maintenant pour les dénoncer
vu le choc qu'ils ont connue avec cette
mise en lumière de d'un éventuel cas sur
la personne à qui il faisait confiance
au quotidien maintenant si jamais il ya
d'autres alertes ou d'autres faits qui
seront portées à ma connaissance bien
sûr que j'agirai en conséquence